so one of the companies that I looked at
uh that has failed in in recent months
is British Vault a British startup which
looked at um battery making and it was
going to be one of the two gigafactories
of making batteries in the UK they went
bust in January and the former CEO has
since then come out and blamed you know
to your to your question blamed
government instability you know during
the time over the last over the last
year when they were struggling
financially they had three different
Prime Ministers they have numerous
different secretaries of State dealing
with them on in different ways um he
directly pointed the finger of blame at
the treasury as well for not releasing
funding because of the political
instability so I think part of it is
just that we've had so many leaders you
know talk about Boris Johnson's 10-point
plan that was only two years ago right
and now we've got a leader who's totally
watering down Net Zero so I think that
is also a part of it and maybe after the
next election things will stabilize a
bit more but the British political
turmoil that can't be bed out I think